welcome to the heavy spoiler show i'm
your host paul aka your friendly
neighborhood spoiler man
and this video i brought you know what
i'm gonna bring it back for just one
last time
welcome to the heavy spoilers show i'm
your host definition aka your friendly
neighborhood spoiler man
and we have a hell of a lot of things to
talk about if you've been keeping up to
date with spider-man 3 then you'll know
that over the last three months has been
a hell of a lot of rumors about how toby
mcguire is coming back
andrew garfield's coming back they're
all coming back for this
last film and kind of uniting across the
multiverse to
to take down the bad guys like electro
who
you know is he's the big the big bad we
all want to see
in addition to this there's been rumors
about dr octopus and
craven the hunter and it seems like sony
are really throwing everything they can
at this film to make it
as good as possible i'm of course very
hyped
but i've kind of been a bit skeptical as
we've not had any behind-the-scenes
looks at either mcguire
garfield or or really anything to
confirm these rumors beyond
jamie foxx basically posting a
multiverse poster
now comic-con xp is about to get into
full swing
and there are thoughts that something
big will be announced here that may
either be the spider-man 3 title
or just the entire cast list and what we
can expect in the film
however it looks like someone's going to
be getting fired
as there was an international sony video
that
teased all three peter parkers in the
upcoming movie
this video was posted this morning and
it's since been taken down
which tends to mean that someone's in
trouble and they shouldn't have released
this this early
now we're not sure whether there's going
to be some announcement this weekend but
it's comic con such a big event that
anything could go down
and there could be an amazing lineup
reveal or absolutely nothing
the comic con this year i think was
actually overshadowed quite a lot by
by the justice league snyder cup panels
and you know what
they kind of need something to to really
sell to us that 2021 is gonna be a big
year
we are of course getting a lot of
delayed movies in that one so
you know they need something big to to
to make fans excited
now toby mcguire and andrew garfield are
both rumored to reprise their respective
roles
and i remember this story being leaked
by annie signor a couple of months ago
we didn't really get any word from the
official trade so it kind of got brushed
to the side
but there still has been rumblings that
things are going on now sony's latino
america youtube channel
did drop a teaser this morning that had
spanish text in it
over the top of andrew garfield toby
mcguire and tom holland
because the video was taken down i can't
show you it but i did manage to capture
it before it was removed and
you know if you if you just look on
twitter you'll see that a lot of people
are verifying this story
now the text itself said who is your
favorite spider-man
you don't have to choose in the marvel
multiverse
anything can happen and in spider-man 3
it's very possible that you will see
everyone yes
three peter parkers saving the world
together
so so whoever put that out yet i tell
you what mate you better start tighten
up your cv because you are getting fired
for that
but clearly it's saying that all these
three spider-men
are gonna be in the film and it does
verify the rumors that we've heard
floating around about the project
spider-man into the spider-verse was of
course a massive film
that kind of set the groundwork for for
anyone returning really and when jay
jonah jameson popped up at the end of
far from home
you kind of got the feeling that wow
they're really starting to open the door
here and anyone could come back at this
point
nothing is going to be bigger than
having andrew garfield and toby maguire
back
and considering that both kind of got
cancelled projects
for example sam raimi was meant to be
making spider-man 4.
andrew garfield got fired before he got
to do the amazing spider-man 3.
you know this is gonna be sort of a
redemption for them to to say
farewell to the character in a way
that's gonna completely rock the entire
marvel multiverse
and my fragile little brain so i'm of
course very excited for this
we don't have official confirmation on
it yet but when the sony
latino america channel is putting this
out you know
it it does seem pretty obvious that
that's what's going to be going down
they've clearly had to pay someone to
make this teaser and the fact that it's
been privated probably means it's coming
out very soon
so yeah sorry guy whoever you are
maybe you should held off until your
boss gave you the word but
fans are of course massively excited and
hopefully it means that at ccxp
we're gonna get a big announcement and
you'll be like down that spoiler man he
did it again he predicted the entire
thing
if we don't know you know it'll probably
be in the next couple of weeks that
something comes out
and i'm very confident at the moment
that this story will turn out to be true
now obviously i'd love to hear your
thoughts on it so make sure you comment
below and let me know
and if you're as excited as i am then
make sure you hit that thumbs up button
and also check out our breakdown of
batman begins which goes over the best
easter eggs in that entire film
it's one of the best videos i've ever
made i think so i'm i'll be
absolutely over the moon if you checked
it out so what the hell are you doing
you should have already clicked it by
now
now don't forget that we're giving away
three copies of the lord of the rings 4k
box set and all you have to do to begin
with the chance of winning is like the
video
subscribe to the channel and drop a
comment below the winner is going to be
chosen at random on the 30th of december
so make sure you get involved
if you want to support the channel and
get to see content early then please
consider clicking the join button below
you can come chat to us on our discord
server linked in the description or
heavy spoilers on twitter
thanks for listening through all that
rambling you've been the best
i've been definition this time and i'll
see you
next time take care peace
[Music]
do
[Music]
you